hey everybody it's Jimmy again with
bright insight today I'm going to talk
with you about the pyramids of Egypt and
how literally what we were taught in
school and what is still actively being
taught in public schools and at the
university level is completely
inaccurate for example the Great Pyramid
of Giza has two million three hundred
thousand stone blocks by the way that's
just an estimate I've heard estimates as
much as 2.6 million but these blocks
range anywhere from 2 to 80 tons
eight-zero do the math on that guys
we're talking 160,000 pound stone blocks
or or as little as four thousand pounds
of course and these stone blocks are
made from granite limestone and basalt a
combination of it and they originate
from the Aswan and elephantine island
queries which are located literally 500
miles away now there's many theories on
how they were able to transport these
massive stone blocks from such an
extreme distance but that's something
we'll cover in another video because I
have some things that are far more
interesting to discuss that will make
your heads absolutely blown with this
with these facts that you probably have
not heard before
now these 2.3 million stone blocks are
all various different sizes and
dimensions that they weren't just one
offset they were able to manufacture
okay this one is this size we're going
to make a million of these no in fact
they fit in and they have a very unique
fitting for each individual block that
they're not just stacked on top of each
other but they're intertwined to create
an incredible force of stability and
interlocking connectiveness now the
Great Pyramid of Giza sits on 13 acres
it's nearly 500 feet tall and each of
its bases is more than 750 feet long
interesting fact that you probably
haven't heard before
is that the ratio of the pyramids height
to its circumference at at its base is
equal to the value of pi 3.14 I doubt it
now something else that's very
interesting is that if you were to take
a nine thousand pound pyramid stone and
say that it's about three and a half
feet by three and a half
feet which isn't uncommon to find it
would take literally if you were to
unload this if men did this without
machinery like they want us to believe
like you know as bunch of slaves doing
this if you were to have three people on
each side and keep in mind we're talking
a three and a half foot dimension but if
you can fit three people on each side of
three and a half feet which would be a
tight squeeze each individual person be
lifting more than 900 pounds hmm that
doesn't sound right does it
here's another interesting fact if you
could cut carve shape in place ten
stones a day it would take more than six
hundred and sixty-four years to make
just one pyramid guys we're talking
moving these things cutting and shaping
them moving them over 500 miles and by
the way you have to place them precisely
because the to make a pyramid requires
extremely advanced mathematical formulas
and equations because if you don't place
them precisely by the time you get to
the top you don't have a pyramid you
have a corkscrew shaped mess and you're
completely screwed another interesting
fact that many people are not aware of
is that mainstream Egyptian antiquities
want you to believe that the pyramids
were utilized for tombs that's what they
were they were tombs however they never
found tombs inside the pyramids yeah
look it up but what's more interesting
is the fact that the amazing the
absolutely amazing acoustic capabilities
that are within the pyramids within the
galleries and the various like Queen's
Chamber for example like literally you
tube this the acoustics are so
unbelievably impressive that there's no
way that this was an accident look it up
now here's a big question why would
anyone go to such an incredible task of
building even just one pyramid like
could we even do this today well okay
yeah people say yeah sure we could but
what would it take how much money would
that project cost not only would it be
the most expensive and most elaborate
project ever constructed but in modern
times but I would say that no one could
afford to do it because it would cost an
untold amount of billions of dollars it
would acquire an unbelievable amount of
manpower and effort like what what union
are they get a higher to get this [ __ ]
done like literally if you if it takes
four years to build
modern baseball stadium like what do you
think it takes to make a pyramid and
when you look at these pictures guys the
precision that's necessary to form these
pyramids and do what they did or to even
have the internal chambers constructed
within the pyramids in the shapes and
the stones to interlock the way they do
require such unbelievable precision and
accuracy that it is my numbing and to be
able to construct and make this thing
happen today well it's kind of
far-fetched in many many ways now
another interesting fact is the
alignment of True North with the Great
Pyramid and that it's within an era of
three sixtieth of a degree of era of
being perfectly aligned to true north
now we do know that because of the
precession of the Earth's and its tilt
over time that True North does change we
know this so what's interesting is that
it must have been at one point aligned
perfectly to true north
seeing as how accurate it is today
that's pretty amazing guys what we were
told about ancient civilization is far
far more complicated than what we ever
imagined and that they had to have some
sort of advanced technology or machinery
in order to construct the pyramid and
the evidence is all over the place
anyways guys I'm Jimmy this is bright
insight like and subscribe I have many
more videos for you to enjoy and have
many more coming be blessed all